you welcome to this video and we are
playing again here with the all-time
high currently on record against blue ya
dis i played this guy in the session
even but he gained really lots of points
quite remarkable how i think this is one
way to play it ok just allows me to take
interesting ok so we playing an old
Indian where he gave me this Bishop ok
the position is relatively close but
still still I'd like I like my like my
bishops there so how do we go about this
Queen d2 trying to open up the queenside
probably it's not a very attractive
position from like it's quite one-sided
ok where's he going to a seven or why
doesn't it's not getting in b5 or
something like that ok that was idea and
maybe bishop d 8b 6 me know that's a
viable way to play ok maybe i can
threaten to take on c6 ok d cakes be
cakes i have no check check here i still
wonder what happens if i take on c5
sometimes this ugly looking procedures
not bad for concrete reasons
take sting nightly yeah that's
interesting night a form takes beat eggs
and c5 that that is a favorable opening
of the position he avoided that but i
have c 5 now how is he playing 90 for
something like that this should be just
a bit better for white queen III or yeah
i probably have look see one was also
quite viable but yeah I'm just a bit
better taking their that their queen
before no Queen before I take you five
thirty eight I don't know yeah okay
let's put this one c4 and get the bishop
active okay maybe I should have avoided
that ins okay I wonder ever should go a
four or not
not sure about that let's play it I'm
not a lot really not really sure hope
this 698 2d6 is what he wants to do for
watching exchange hmm i cannot get
before in in a good way at the moment it
seems okay but let's let's do it anyway
you cannot play I cannot just grab that
I like see five or so this may be a
night on the sixth so very nicely
positioned piece so a five hmm
look a one looks wrong it just looks
wrong a 596 a 596 a six and now I know I
lost I lost the thread year out of this
very nice position that's kind of a
shame really shape it was very nice out
of the opening this disposition I came
um what about look b7 I can move the
King so no no tactical no tactical
miracle for me not really disappointing
that I didn't get more out of that 90 86
was a was a big problem there in terms
of making and making any progress time
warning
hmm not sure if he has an easy win here
however I mean time wise maybe but f5 is
an interesting way to try
check
no this squid something hanging 'if I've
nc6 check check check okay let's
approach check g3 man
before us nothing giving me the porn
almost check I can't he can just trade
of course Jim white resins Jim that that
position losing it is really bad while
it's just right is just completely
dominating him Queen 87 as a move that
really really should have seen I mean
white is so better that I'm losing is
really bad really bad I should what what
should i do maybe just double them I
mean a four was I wasn't sure about the
move maybe it's not a good idea double
on the sea porn yeah probably yeah kingi
790 86 helped him a lot I should
probably just double but there's
something like this or this move here
then go from them it's not easy maybe it
can defend us you defend his weaknesses
them but still losing is really terrible
ok that's it with 2500 you lose one game
it costs you in 19 points ok well thanks
for watching